welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Ahsoka
episode 5 Shadow Warrior a love letter
to clone wars with Hayden Christensen as
a clone wars era Anakin Skywalker and
young Ahsoka Tano played by Ariana
Greenblatt AKA young Gamora and Avengers
Infinity War but who exactly was our
Shadow Warrior this episode was it the
living Force embodying ahsoka's old
master or the Dark Side of Darth Vader
finishing the malachor fight in the
world Between Worlds or something even
cooler I'm gonna break down all the
Clone Wars callbacks and other
interesting production details that you
might have missed from the music and the
sound design to amazing attention to
detail in the lightsaber choreography of
this episode and yeah folks I did it
again it's like 2 A.M Pacific time as I
record this after spending eight hours
writing this analysis what am I doing
but you know what I approached these
breakdowns as a labor of love not just
as like a review or a reaction or a list
of Star Wars trivia or a bunch of weird
takes to make you feel like less of a
Star Wars fan I do this because I am so
grateful to Dave falloni and all the
cast and crew for giving us these great
stories and I just want to celebrate the
craftsmanship that they put into this
and I'm grateful to you for letting this
channel be part of your Ahsoka
experience so thank you thank you thank
you and let's dive in okay we open as
always with the lucasfilm sequence of
Vader 3PO clone trooper helmet HK
assassin Droid Baroque huyang
Stormtrooper Chopper and sabine's helmet
and finally this episode pays off a spot
in that culture helmet as this episode
gives us two cameos of Clone Trooper Rex
both when he was the captain during the
Clone Wars season 1 era on ryloth and
when he was a commander of the 332nd
company in the siege of Mandalore in
Clone Wars season 7. but really just
take a moment to appreciate the music
here
closed captioning calls this soft
ethereal music composer Kevin kiner
tweeted that the music of this episode
would be special with a video of his kid
Diana kiner on flute they were
co-credited with Kevin and Ludwig
jorenson and Noah garlic for writing
that sick
from episode one and in this intro we're
really hearing the purr the flute mixed
with the singing bursts of the flute
like ahsoka's patient current age trying
to reconcile with her inpatient youth We
Begin this episode on ctOS and we get
this close-up of the pedestal that held
the spear where Morgan ellisman summoned
the Green Knight sister Flames we see
how this pedestal is forked kind of like
the shape of Vader's tower on Mustafar
and we see the split halves of that
spear in Gears and cogs now exposed it
really was simple old school Machinery
Rubik's cubable by any art history nerd
that this device was meant to open up to
and Morgan and ellesmith cheated by
using witchcraft to jailbreak it they
violated the intent of whoever the
ancient Star Wars Archimedes was who
engineered this into kythera Jason we
pointed that last week where's his
father Kanan Jairus pauldron on his
shoulder with that three-pronged sigil
that Kanan shared with the Doom wolf on
loophole and Rebels and there's actually
a photograph of Kanan Jairus pinned to
Hera's dashboard and it's hard to tell
but it does kind of look like they might
have used Freddie Prince Jr as a model
for it as he was the actor who voiced
Kanan on Rebels and since Jason Plays
such an important role this episode of
sensing the lightsaber combat through
the world Between Worlds they actually
teased Jason's lightsaber Hearing in
this moment as we actually hear a
lightsaber hum in the sound mix right
before Jason pops his head out from
behind Chopper
who Yang laments I told them to stay
together but they never listened they
never listen yes David Tennant voices
this to be so mournful and his poor
Droid eyes just droop sorrowfully it was
he in episode 4 who begged them to stay
together it was only because osoka did
not see Sabine and assume that she died
that led to both of their failures and
yes huyang repeats they never listen and
you kind of feel like he's talking about
all of the Jedi in general like all the
Younglings he guided to their kyber
crystals and instructed how to build
their Hills eventually grew up into
these stubborn Warriors who got involved
in political Wars and distrusted
deceived and destroyed each other indeed
they never listen so from here we cut to
this episode's title reveal Shadow
Warrior and yes we feel like who Yang is
talking about the most infamous node in
this Legacy of wayward Jedi who never
listened Anakin Skywalker but it's not
just Anakin there's a cool deeper
meaning to this that I'll discuss at the
end of the video we rejoin Anakin and
Ahsoka in the world Between Worlds now
I've explained this Cosmic dimension in
a number of videos most recently this
one actually goes into Dave Bologna's
actual intention and proves why you know
at the end of the day it's probably not
best to get too carried away with the
deep cut fan theories about the gods of
mortis and whatnot when it comes to this
kind of thing because really this is
ahsoka's subjective experience it's
about her dealing with what she brought
into this place meanwhile for a fuller
context of really everything you need to
know from Rebels please check out our
four-part Rebels recap series very very
informational and helpful so Dave filoni
wrote and directed this episode but the
cinematographer was Queen Tran who
frames every shot with stunning
composition like as we cut to Anakin's
view of Ahsoka notice the path behind
her curves off to the left but when we
see ahsoka's view of Anakin his path
ends it just kind of ends in a
cul-de-sac there Ahsoka took some turns
to get here but to follow Anakin down
his path would lead to the end of the
road so the two greet each other you
look the same you look old
well that happens yes they D aged Hayden
Christensen so that he would look the
most like her memory of him from right
before Revenge of the Sith but Anakin
comments on ahsoka's older appearance
because yeah she's played by Rosario
Dustin and yeah the character would be
like 50 now aging older than he was in
Revenge of the Sith and now five or so
years after returning the Jedi might be
getting closer to his age at his time of
death even in asuka's various eras of
Animation between clone wars and Rebels
she goes through a dramatic physical
change into adulthood Anakin says I'm
here to finish your training it's a
little late for that when it's never too
old to learn Snips remember in episode 1
of the series Ahsoka told Hera that
Anakin ever completed her training he
had spent years as her master during
Clone Wars seasons one through five but
Ahsoka abruptly left the Jedi Order at
the end of season 5 and in Rebels season
2 episode 18 Ahsoka watches an old
recording that Anakin had made for her
as he taught her form 4 lightsaber
combat so Ahsoka is truly longed for
closure with her mentor and Anakin
explains the point of this final lesson
live
or die this episode teaches us that
living or dying isn't really a question
of lightsaber skills it's letting go of
what you fear to lose one of the things
we heard in the rebels World between
World episode was Yoda to Anakin from
Revenge of the Sith Rejoice for those
around you who transform into the force
attachment leads to jealousy train
yourself to let go of everything you've
fear to lose and now Ahsoka is most
afraid to lose Sabine and that is what's
holding her back because it's a lesson
that Anakin never really could have
taught her but here Ahsoka says I won't
bite you
I've heard that before this is a
fascinating response from Anakin because
it sounds like it's referring to when
Luke Skywalker in Return of the Jedi
says this to Vader as he tosses his
saber I will not fight you father which
would mean that this Anakin would have
the memory of being Darth Vader and
dueling his son in the Battle of Endor
something that Ahsoka probably wouldn't
know about unless she and Luke chatted
about it you know when they were
crashing Boba Fett's miniseries it could
also refer to win Ahsoka face Vader on
malachor in the rebels season 2 finale
initially she said that she wouldn't
leave Anakin but then she swore to
avenge and again revenge is not the Jedi
way
I am no Jedi either way this is not a
friendly sparring match between master
and Apprentice this is really a rematch
between Ahsoka and Vader it's meant to
provide closure for that conflict and
Anakin doesn't hold back his aggressive
lunges are just like his combat style
against Obi-Wan and Mustafar and at one
point he stabs his saber directly
forward which is Palpatine's favorite
move actually I want to give a common
diploment to K dot Remick on last week's
breakdown for pointing out how ahsoka's
stance while fighting morocc in episode
4 was the same as Palpatine's in Revenge
of the Sith amazing insight and thank
you to everyone who writes these kind of
thoughtful comments it really means a
lot to be able to engage with you all in
the comments with this kind of great
conversation so Hera searches for Ahsoka
using the same bulky Scanner with the
antenna that Han Solo used to search for
Luke on Hoth and The Empire Strikes Back
Carson Teva comes in and says senator
rogana says she can only give us cover
for so long ah he's talking about Leia
Organa I freaking love that Leia knows
Hera and knows Carson and she's just
helping them sneak around like this this
of course is going to be part of Leia's
ongoing campaign to form a resistance
Fleet outside the new republic
government oversight though at this
point she's still a senator at some
point in the future she's going to be
run out of office once the broader
public knows that her father was Darth
Vader this is something that gets
explored in Claudia Gray's bloodline
novel now Jason says he's senses
Something In The Water he and Hera
turned a chopper who chimes in
yeah it's just one of my favorite dumb
things to try to decode what day polony
utters as chopper for all these moments
in here I'm pretty sure he says well I
got nothing but Hera closes her eyes and
she listens with her son
lightsabers
[Music]
yes they mix in John Williams Force
theme here all season long Kevin keiner
has flirted with William's themes with
light motifs but he just Alters little
things about them but here he leans hard
into it Jason is able to hear this from
the world Between Worlds telling us that
it's not just ahsoka's delusion down
there it is a real realm that she is
visiting and that everyone with a forced
connection is able to tap into it and a
reminder that the runes at the edge of
the Stonehenge platform are the language
that we began to decode in our closing
credits map translation video definitely
a good watch these runes translate to
2100 which I think might just be a
distance to pritia not really sure but I
absolutely love Paul sudden Lee's
delivery here Jason has abilities his
father Kanan Jairus was a Jedi
okay yeah just a reminder that most
people in this universe think the force
is really silly and really spooky okay
so back to Anakin and ahsoka's duel and
again it Twirls his lightsaber this is
the same move that he and Obi wanted to
mirror off each other in the Mustafar
room where Anakin and kill all the
separatist leaders you remember that
moment
and then Anakin does another Palpatine
stab but Ahsoka repels it by doing the
same behind the back block pose that we
often saw Anakin doing during the
prequel era and that familiarity is what
seems to catch him off guard because he
allows Ahsoka to get a solid kick on him
but what Ahsoka hadn't noticed is that
Anakin's aggression forced her down his
end of the path to that dead end
cul-de-sac I pointed out earlier that is
all he wanted to do here to just lead
Ahsoka to this dead end so that he could
move on to the next phase of his lesson
I haven't taught you everything yet so
he slices the path to break the floor
beneath ahsoka's feet kinda like the
ball rug breaking Gandalf's path and
causing her to fall through the floor
but it's also kind of like the way Vader
fell through Lord during their duel on
malachor in Rebels right when Ahsoka got
pulled through into the world Between
Worlds so Ahsoka tumbles down this
rabbit hole through these pink clouds
and lands on some terrain but now she is
younger Ariana Greenblatt yes young
Gabor from Infinity war and a number of
other roles like shoes and Barbie this
year playing the youth version of snips
that we got to know in the early seasons
of Clone Wars this casting is so good
Greenblatt is perfect in this role we
see clone troopers running past her some
of them with a blue-lined armor and the
long rifles and we see a younger version
of Anakin
master
hurry up Snips young Ahsoka is back to
wearing her headband in the beaded
headdress that goes down the back of her
look who that Ahsoka had an original
Teenage character design though luckily
they don't have the Goofy character
design that like shows her mid-drift but
we also see that she has her original
lightsaber which had a green kyber
Crystal and then Anakin hidden
Christensen actually looks pretty good
here he has the same haircut in the Jedi
armor that the animators made for him in
the Clone Wars series and in the
background of that fog of War you can
see a republic atte or at T Walker which
would eventually evolve into the
Imperial at at or atat we also see an
laat transport or lat transport gunship
which was first introduced in Attack of
the Clones we're back in the Clone Wars
and it's live action I can't believe
we're seeing this but yes this is not a
flashback because Ahsoka still has her
adult mind she's kind of reliving the
memory this is the Clone Wars yeah no
kidding this is one of our first
missions now they are on the planet of
ryloth I'm basing this on the Twilights
that we see in the background in the
aftermath of the battle this is likely
the ryloth arc at the end of season 1 of
Clone Wars episode 19 storm over ryla
episode 20 innocence of ryloth and
episode 21 Liberty of ryloth in episode
19 Anakin and Ahsoka lead some clone
troopers to break a separatist blockade
of ryloth but Ahsoka disobeys Anakin's
orders and she gets a bunch of Clone
Pilots killed episode 20 follows Obi-Wan
liberating the Droid occupy by town on
brylab and then episode 21 shows their
eventual Victory with Mace Windu
introducing us to Hera's father the
twilik freedom fighter Champs and Doula
so I think these Desert Sands are the
Dixon desert that makes Windu credits
Obi-Wan with securing on ryla's Southern
hemisphere in episode 21 and since we
didn't really see where Anakin and
Ahsoka were for those second two
episodes I think we are seeing the
events that Anakin reported to Palpatine
and Yoda here my Fighters have secured
control of the space around ryloth we
have the separatist Cruisers On The Run
and yes one of these blue-plated clone
troopers is Captain Rex because the
episode credits listen where Morrison as
playing both commander and Captain Rex
yeah that is Rex talking to Anakin and
the twiliks there and yes just a
reminder that ryloth is Hera's Homeworld
where in Rebels she tried to retrieve
her pressure his family category that
Jason now likely has a bead on so part
of what Jason is sensing through the
world Between Worlds is the history that
directly involved his maternal
grandfather Champs and Doula young
Ahsoka places her hand on this wounded
clone trooper and he pluses his hand on
hers and you know that we're just
supposed to imagine that's 2002 to wear
more since based under those rappings
but this isn't just Ahsoka showing her
emotional attachment to these Fighters
she is still feeling horrible over her
decision in storm of ryloth I got a
bunch of these guys killed and actually
the music we hear In This Moment is
Kevin keiner's burying the Dead music
that played in The Clone Wars finale
over shots of Ahsoka bearing members of
the 332nd
Ahsoka asks Anakin but our mistakes cost
that doesn't bother you of course it
does this
this isn't what I train for yeah young
Ahsoka is recognizing how traumatic it
was for young Jedi to transition from
peacekeepers to military commanders it's
part of why this series tagline was
Warrior Outcast Rebel Jedi which we
Embrace with our Ahsoka inspired fulcrum
shirt which you can get at nerd
riot.shop it's one of the best ways to
support what we're doing here in new
rock stars Anakin talks about his place
in this weird Legacy Family Tree look
when Obi-Wan taught me we were keepers
of the peace this Echoes what makes
Windu worried about in Attack of the
Clones wait keepers of the peace not
soldiers but Anakin continues but now
to win this war
I have to teach you to be a soldier is
that all I'll have to teach my own
Padawan one day how to fight do you even
want a Padawan it's fun for Anakin
Star Wars Canon came from just a chat
between George Lucas and Dave filoni
about whether Anakin Skywalker ever had
a Padawan George Lucas is like yeah yeah
he did actually and Anakin brushes off
how much he really hates being a teacher
I'm joking how can you joke at a time
like this what would you prefer yes just
another acknowledgment of the Clone Wars
series and how Anakin and Ahsoka will
often joke around in the middle of
battle here we learn it's just how
they're able to get through it Ahsoka
asks what if I want to stop fighting and
you'll die now at this point I don't
think this is the actual transcript of
the memory of Anakin talking I don't
think he ever actually said this to
Ahsoka really this is like ahsoka's
impression of future Vader seeping in
because as she watches them charge off
with Rex and the others an explosion
briefly changes a silhouette to that of
Darth Vader and his lightsaber goes from
Blue to Red it looks awesome but it's
not just Anakin's change it's the fact
that when he's Anakin he splits by clone
troopers his brothers but when he's
Vader the clone troopers banish and he
is alone and thank you to better help
for sponsoring this video we here at new
rockstars love animal analyzing things
and we're pretty good at it if you want
to understand why a certain character
acts a certain way we can tell you that
but if you want to understand what's
going on with yourself you should talk
to a professional by using better help
with better help you can tap into a
network of over 30 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues whether you
have a clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
going through a rough patch therapy can
give you tools to approach your life in
a very different way if you click the
link in the description you'll see how
easy it is to sign up and get matched
with a therapist to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are better help will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you and if you
don't really fit with that therapist
which is a common thing with therapy you
can easily switch to a therapist at no
additional charge without stressing
about insurance who is in your network
or anything like that if you're
struggling consider online therapy with
better help click the link in the
description or visit betterhelp.com New
rockstars to help support this Channel
and get you 10 off your first month with
better help now I'm pretty sure that
Asuka reaction here is not what Young
Ahsoka actually saw and did in the
actual Battle of ryloth from Clone Wars
we are really back to a subjective
impression of this memory adult Ahsoka
reliving this moment with the knowledge
of what Anakin would become because
really technically that's what memories
are we don't really remember things
exactly as they happened when we think
back on our memory we are remembering
how we felt the last time we thought
about that event every memory we have is
a derivation of the last time we thought
about that event so as we get older it's
diminishing returns in a complex web of
emotions as we've thought back through
our life and yes seeing Anakin suddenly
turning into Vader is just like the
moment and the lothal Jedi Temple in
Rebels season 2 episode 18 where her
vision Vatican turned into a vision
evader and the flickering aspect of it
recalls Ezra's view of Palpatine and the
rebels finale and pieces of that lothal
Jedi Temple now the three X-Wing Pilots
left after the eye of Scion took off in
episode 4 are Carson tiva Lander that's
Brandon Wayne who along with Latif
Crowder does the physical work for the
Mandalorian dinjarin and jinsu played by
ciao no mova while piloting with that
photo of Kanan looking right at her
Harris says I got us out here Chasing
Ghosts yeah ghost pilot Chasing Ghosts
nice wordplay and she asks for Yang
where are they
people don't just vanish Into Thin Air
well no
normally no yeah who Yang monster that
sometimes whether it's Obi-Wan or Yoda
or night brother maroque sometimes that
is just how these people go the ghost
skims waves leading to this awesome
transition to the sounds of blasters and
lightsabers
okay so now Ahsoka slightly older now
wielding two blue lightsabers finds
herself in the siege of Mandalore
depicted in Clone Wars season 7 episodes
9 through 12 which is set concurrently
with the events of Revenge of the Sith
see by season 5 Ahsoka had begun to use
her green lightsaber and a shorter
yellow green Shoto both of which she
lost on Coruscant at the end of season 5
during the drama with that false
accusation of her bombing the Jedi
Temple that led to her parting ways with
the order so these two blue blades
actually came from Anakin later on in
season seven when they reunited right
before they parted ways Anakin to the
Battle of Coruscant that we saw in
Revenge of the Sith and Ahsoka to the
siege of Mandalore that we saw in Clone
Wars season 7 in 2020 set in the city of
tsundari she was helping bokotan
liberate it from Maul again these two
events were happening at the same time
and it's why Anakin doesn't remember it
because he wasn't there now Ahsoka duels
with more confidence now and Ariana and
Greenblatt does a really good job aging
herself throughout this episode now she
carries herself with ahsoka's more jaded
stride I don't know what it is about her
just crossing her arms Asoka or Hayden
Christensen Crossing his arms and
looking over at Snips it just perfectly
evoking what we remember from Clone Wars
now the mandalorians as she fights have
red and black armor with horned helmets
these are members of Maul's Death Watch
after Maul took over that group in
season 5 killing their previous leader
previousla with a darksaber and even
after Maul's temporary capture by
Sidious this branch of the death watch
stayed loyal to Maul and fashioned their
armor to look like him meanwhile the
clone troopers did the same for Ahsoka
part of the 501st Battalion broke off to
form the new 332nd led by Commander Rex
and they painted their helmets to evoke
ahsoka's orange and white to grew to
markings you can actually see some of
those helmets in the background in the
scene and we actually here to where
Morrison's voice as Rex nice work
Commander
we'll secure the perimeter now as you
can see Rex didn't do the orange paint
he just kind of did the markings in blue
and if you look back at that scene of
ryloth that kind of looks like they just
made one helmet for Rex that's okay we
can we can forgive that now all this
would be right before Ahsoka would run
back in the mall and have her epic duel
with him and that would lead right into
order 66. so this is a pivotal moment in
history where she's talking with Anakin
and Anakin says Soca within you will be
everything I am all the knowledge I
possess just as I inherited Knowledge
from my master and he from his who are
part of Legacy we are reminded of Ahsoka
and huyang's line about ahsoka's Legacy
of atypical Jedi and just remember the
links of the chain are Sabine Ahsoka
Anakin Obi-Wan Qui-Gon Dooku and Yoda
all them pretty weird but Anakin also
Echoes what Yoda will tell Anakin's son
in The Last Jedi I think one of the most
important lines in all of Star Wars
we have what they grow Beyond
that is the true burden of all Masters
as much as I love the title of Shadow
Warrior and again I'm going to explain
why at the end of this video I think a
really good implicit title of this
episode would just be the burden of all
Masters Ahsoka responds but my part of
that Legacy is one of death
in war
but you're more than that
but for Ahsoka more means more powerful
more dangerous than anyone ever realized
but Anakin gets fed up and he says is
that what this is about back to the
beginning yes so Anakin circles back to
his words in the beginning of the lesson
live
or die but this time the blade is Vader
red and he faces away from her just as
he initially did to Obi-Wan and Mustafar
and his eyes burn red as they did when
the lava burned his flesh and the hate
took over but really there it was the
skin around his eyes that turned red his
pupils were more orange yellow here they
are just red because something different
is happening here and Kevin Gainer kicks
in with some intense porn music
[Music]
yes this is totally the soprano vocal
notes from Duel of the Fates foreign
now what is really happening here this
is not truly evil Vader taking over this
is ahsoka's subconscious projection of
Anakin wearing a performative mask
because he realizes what haunts Ahsoka
is not her role in War's past but really
her guilt over what Anakin became after
she left him so he is playing this part
to help Ahsoka work through this fear of
a failed student-teacher relationship
Ahsoka goes for her own Palpatine lunch
and Anakin catches it disappointed he
twists her arm back and kicks her
through the fog and adult Ahsoka lands
back in the world Between Worlds
yes that is Vader's breathing there and
the lightning flashes to flicker him
into Vader charging at her it's like
when Ezra saw palpatina Sidious to the
rebels finale but really what's
Happening Here is Anakin is saying okay
Snips you really need that rematch with
Vader after malachor because the fight
was prematurely ended by the world
Between Worlds huh fine I'll give you
Vader this is what you want let's go
let's get it out of your system Anakin
says you lack conviction yes they did a
voice effect on Hayden's voice to make
it sound like it was filtered through
Vader's mask kind of like when we heard
both Matt Lanter and James Earl Jones
voice in that malachor fight and when
they fight Ahsoka crosses her white
Sabers to catch Anakin's red forming
this cool asterisk image echoing a very
similar shot in their duel on malachor
and Rebels this duel is then finally
finishing that one it's just kind of fun
to watch this and think about how this
is the Darth Vader that Palpatine wanted
and because of Obi-Wan scarring the crap
out of him Vader was forever limited to
a techno organic suit which don't get me
wrong looks awesome in Star Wars would
not be Star Wars without it but let's be
honest Hayden is on fire here here
Ahsoka is only able to defeat Anakin
when her lightsabers get knocked out of
her hand and she switches to using only
evasive maneuvers and takes control of
his red lightsaber and that disarming
happens off-screen it's the same exact
way that Anakin disarms Dooku when they
fought in front of Palpatine and Revenge
of the Sith and so we think we are
headed for a beheading Ahsoka even steps
in close so that the red glows in her
eyes too here is when the hate is
closest to her grasp and what does she
do she deactivates the saber she tosses
it aside and she says I choose to live
she makes a different Choice than Anakin
made with Dooku she chooses to live and
I love how Hayden shows that evil
melting away from his face he looks down
and he looks back up at Ahsoka The Mask
has been lifted he's back to his
good-natured mentor There's Hope for you
yet it's just another good lesson from
Clone Wars era Anakin and it's awesome
see balen had put Ahsoka back in a toxic
headspace of thinking she was part of a
cursed Legacy of failed mentors Sabine
in her eyes was just evidence of this
failure so this lesson between life and
death is really Ahsoka acquiring a new
perspective on mentorship to see her
training not as failed but just
incomplete it's the same way she sees
her mentorship with Sabine now just as
Anakin appeared in this space he
vanishes behind the same shoulder
there's an incredible visual where One
path of the world between world
collapses in on ahsoka's path forming a
line of a reflective water surface
briefly we see two mirrored ahsokas and
Ahsoka sinks into herself so the two
polar ends of ahsoka's Consciousness
find each other in the middle and
finally she reaches a balance since
everything Ahsoka saw in the world
Between Worlds was blue and fluid now it
melts back into the sea it's just
implied that Ahsoka physically
envisioned this experience while
floating in the ocean the entire time as
the force manipulated the water around
her into a construct where she could
work through these issues as Ahsoka
floats her arms are outstretched in the
Christ pose as we are witnessing the
character undergoing a resurrection
X-Wing pilot jensu Dives in coast guard
style to get her and later pulls her up
and we definitely hear a voice through
the force saying Ahsoka here
is that Anakin calling to her though
because it kind of sounds female could
it be Sabine are the master and
Apprentice finally linked through the
force while ctOS is a planet has always
been stormy up until this point finally
the clouds break and sunlight beams into
Ahsoka to awaken her on her bunk on the
T6 now she doesn't wear her headband so
we see the barrier between her orange
brow and her white lacoo outside Ahsoka
Dons a white garment and later she fully
suits up white these same robes that she
wears in the rebels finale episode
showing how she's completed her journey
into Gandalf the White what we thought
was death was actually transformation
into Enlightenment Ahsoka once again
uses psychometry to read the split
sphere this is Jedi Quinlan boss's old
Force ability to hear a recording of
recent history based on an impression it
leaves on an object or a location mon
Mothman calls in to order Hera and
Ahsoka to return to Coruscant saying the
Senate oversight committee is going to
vote on whether to suspend her command
and they pilot the T6 and the ghost
directly into a pod pergol and the
largest one Looms in right in front of
Ahsoka on the wing she loves going out
on this Wing the imagery and the scale
reminds me of Paula treadise facing the
sand worm Dune down to the baleen these
are whales Brushy teeth dennyville Noob
actually used the same anatomical effect
on the interior mouth of the sand worms
whales have these as filters for the
stuff that flows openly into their
mouths Carson Teva faces New Republic
mon calamari Cruisers led by Captain
Gerard played by acid Davis her first
officer is The ishi Tib race which first
appeared in Return of the Jedi Carson
reminds us that he's from the Adelphi
base which I'm pretty sure is that
X-Wing and y-wing bar that we saw in the
Mandalorian season three Jason says it's
just like the stories you told me how
the whales together and the bad guys far
far away far far away he describes the
events of the rebels finale using the
language of the famous opening blue text
of Star Wars a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away this is the first Star Wars
title that's taken us from one Far Far
Away Galaxy to a completely different
one as Ahsoka uses Force to communicate
with a pergol its massive blue eye looks
at her and like Jonah in the Old
Testament and Pinocchio and Dory and
Marlon and Finding Nemo Ahsoka and
huyang nestled themselves in the belly
of the whale actually riding a sea
animal on some mysterious superparable
current is exactly what Dory and Marlon
do riding Crush through the East
Australian current how old is that Pergo
150 dude and still young Ahsoka tells
huyang we'll just see where it goes it
could go anywhere
I know
that's better than going nowhere this is
the
White having aged out of data this world
and eager to embark on the next great
adventure West through the gray Havens
choir voices ring out as the Pergo swim
past the new Republic Cruisers I love
how you can see the X-Wing docking Bays
as a float past looking so small giving
us a sense of scale compared to the
people who would be in those Bays Gerard
and her Bridge are helpless to just
watch kind of like thrawn on the Chimera
and the rebels finale and there's this
awesome visual effect as the alpha Pergo
passes the engine of the cruiser and its
eye reflects blue it's kind of like when
you take a picture of a cat it gets a
laser eye effect it's because it's part
of the eye called the tepidum lesudim
the pergal charge up and from the other
side of the baleen teeth Ahsoka and
huyangs see this horizontal line of
light with streaks of purple in their
cockpit we do not see the stretching
Stars effect that we were used to seeing
for hyperspace jump in Star Wars because
this version is hidden from us Ahsoka is
only able to see it through this narrow
slit kind of like Oppenheimer watching
the Trinity test through his special eye
gear it's because unlike the world
Between Worlds this is a trip through
the heavens that Mortals are not meant
to see the process of so Ahsoka begins
this episode in the dark with the Shadow
Warrior and she ends bathe in light but
who was the Shadow Warrior exactly what
does that really mean well we are
reminded of Shadow Warrior AKA Akira
kurosawas kagemusha an amazing 1980 film
which had an international version that
was executive produced by George Lucas
so in Japanese akagamusha is a political
decoy someone who impersonates a
politician to draw attention away from
the real leader who might be dead or
alien or under threat it's exactly what
Padme Amidala did with her decoys or
Dave in the movie Dave so in this
episode Anakin performs the kagamusha
role a doppelganger who gives a
theatrical performance to impersonate a
fallen warlord of Darth Vader Darth
Vader himself based on Curacao imagery
of course so that Ahsoka can finally
finish her battle with Vader and learn
her final lesson still ultimately a
shadow a warrior impersonating a ghost
but why do we see ghosts not because of
the ghost's unfinished business but
because of our own please support this
channel by grabbing and Ahsoka inspired
fulcrum shirt available at
nerdright.shop be sure to subscribe to
the break room for episodes of WikiLeaks
or Asoka after show subscribe to all
three channels Linda Rockstar's Network
big thanks to Noah Chen for helping
write and research this breakdown follow
me at eavos following the rockstars
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time bye
[Music]
foreign